on va revenir sur les moments les plus
forts qui se sont déroulés à cannes lors
des derniers jours du festival
regardez 21 ans je souhaite prédire que
l'on ne saura jamais plus le bienvenu et
c'était actrice française noirs ou métis
ou cosigné le livre noir n'est pas mon
métier où elles racontent chacune leur
expérience les vins ne sont pas une
minorité dans le monde
et pourtant notre industrie dit le
contraire nous mettons au défi nos
institutions pour organiser active
mandats parité alors use discours d'agde
ardente où alan jara jean patrick gille
vous aimez et géraldine donc je ne vais
pas vous mettez votre pancartes pourquoi
vous n'avez pas alors moi j'aime pas
parce que d'abord je trouvais que
c'était ni le lieu ni le bon timing pour
pour faire ce discours alors évidemment
je je comprends absolument la douleur
énorme et là et la blessure y immense de
asia argento
mais d'abord qu'un appris qu'elle
blanquette qui a été une militante et
qui a été très très présente pour les
mouvements mitu on a eu la marche des
femmes qui ont été donc ces marches de
cannes qui se sont arrêtés 80 de femmes
militantes et qui ont parlé de ce combat
et je trouvais que c'était pas l'endroit
parce qu'en fait d'abord il ya une
procédure judiciaire
harvey weinstein et dans le caniveau on
le sait et c'est tant mieux
voilà mais je trouvais qu'en fait ça
hystérise le débat encore et encore et
au lieu de comment dire de nier les
femmes et les hommes ça nous divise et
ça ne fait pas avancer le débat
j'aime asia argento et je ne comprends
pas du tout votre discours c'est un cri
du coeur absolu c'est une femme qui a
été brisée et qui le dit devant des
festivaliers qui ne l'écoutent même pas
puisqu'ils sont captivés si elle le dit
c'est parce que c'est nécessaire
cette parole-là doit sortir doit être
prononcée peu importe soit canaux
ailleurs il fallait le dire bravo à elle
mais asia l'a déjà dit agile elle la
démagogie
de nombreuses de nombreuses fois donc en
fait ça n'apporte rien ça n'apporte rien
au débat
quand elle a dit d'ailleurs elle a dû
quitter son pays parce qu'on n'a pas
compris pourquoi elle avait été pendant
cinq ans avec hermé ou einstein et on
n'a pas compris ça justement dont moi
j'aurais aimé que la vierge un taux 10
au jeune femme aux apprenties
comédiennes ne tombez pas dans ce que
j'ai fait moi quand on vous dit vous
devez coucher avec moi pour réussir un
film non dit non révoltez vous je ne
veux pas qu'on victimise les fasse un
pas qu'ont les uns fait les infantilise
pour lui demander théorisé alors qu'elle
est touchée elle est blessée chérie